[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Cloud data
loss prevention
is a fully managed
service designed
to help you discover,
classify, and protect
your most sensitive data.
You can inspect, mask, an
de-identify sensitive data
such as personally identifiable
information or PII, secrets,
and credentials.
Cloud DLP integrates natively
with Security Command Center.
When you use Cloud DLP to scan
your GCP storage repositories,
it can send results directly
to the Security Command Center
dashboard.
Please note.
Cloud DLP uses its own
pricing structure separate
from Security Command
Center Premium.
A link to pricing information
is available in the description
below.
Before you can send
Cloud DLP scan results
to Security Command
Center, you must set up
the following components--
identify GCP storage
repositories,
set Cloud IAM roles, enable
Security Command Center,
enable Cloud DLP, enable
Cloud DLP as a security source
for Security Command Center,
and define a DLP inspect job.
Step one.
Identify a GCP
storage repositories.
You can choose whether you want
to scan your own GCP storage
repository or an example one.
If you want to scan your own
existing cloud storage bucket,
BigQuery table, or Cloud
Datastore kind, first,
open the project that
the repository is in.
In the next steps, you'll enable
Cloud DLP for this project
and its organization.
Step two.
Set Cloud IAM rules.
Before you can use Cloud DLP to
send scan results to Security
Command Center, you'll need to
enable some Cloud IAM rules.
This section requires you
to have the organization
administrator IAM role.
Click on the organization
dropdown list
and select the
organization for what
you want to enable
Security Command Center.
Navigate to IAM and Admin
using the Navigation pane.
Find the user name in the
member column or add a new user.
Add the role, Security Center
Admin and DLP Jobs Editor
and then click Save.
Step three, enable
Security Command Center.
If you are a new user, enable
Security Command Center
following the instructions
in the three-step overview
video linked below.
Step four.
Enable Cloud DLP.
Navigate to the
project you would
like to use to
execute your DLP scan.
The project must be within
the same organization
where you enabled
Security Command Center.
Head to APIs and Services
in the Navigation pane.
Search for Cloud DLP,
API, and enable it.
Step five.
Enable Cloud DLP as
a security source
for Security Command Center.
Go to the Security
Command Center page
and select your organization.
Click Settings in the top
right corner of the page.
Under Integrated Sources,
click the toggle next
to Data Loss Prevention.
Step six.
Define a DLP inspect job.
Go to the Cloud DLP console
and choose your project,
click on Create
Job, enter a name
and select the storage
target that you want to scan.
Configure your scan options.
On the action step, click to
enable Publish the Security
Command Center.
You also have the option to
save the results to BigQuery,
click Create, and run the job.
If you want to surface findings
for additional projects
within your organization, repeat
step six for each storage asset
that you went to inspect.
Now, findings for
Cloud DLP will display
in the Findings tab of the
Security Command Center
dashboard.
Cloud DLP uses information
types or info types
to define what it scans for.
An info type is a
type of sensitive data
such as a name, email
address, telephone number,
identification number, credit
card number, and so on.
You can also define your own
custom info types or tune
detection using
inspection rules.
You can find out more about it
in the Cloud DLP documentation.
In our environment,
we see that there
have been more than 90 Cloud
DLP findings in our organization
such as email addresses,
credit card numbers, and phone
numbers.
Drilling in, let's expand
an email address finding.
We can see it first
occurred on August 25
and is located in the asset
we identified for inspect job.
This is the project in
which the PII was flagged.
We can then click on
the external URI source
and see almost 4,000 PII
findings related to it.
Next, if set up as
part of the DLP job,
we can perform
additional analysis
on this data their BigQuery.
Or we can remove this resource
and remediate these findings
by contacting the owner.
Congratulations.
You've enabled Cloud DLP
for Security Command Center
and learned how to respond
to a finding from it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]